هل تتذكرون حنين حسام ومواد الادهم وانضمت
لهما مؤخرا سلمى الشيمي فتيات التيك توك
او هكذا اصبحت اسماؤهن في وسائل الاعلام
في القضايا التي نصبت لهن ولمثلهن من
الفتيات في السجن بتهمه التعديه على قيم
الاسره المصريه احنا لازم بقى نشيل التيك
توك ونشيل السوشيال ميديا من حياتنا شويه
يا جماعه والله الدنيا زمان كانت لطيفه من
غير سوشيال ميديا لان احنا بنستغلها غلط
لكن احنا طالما في زمن مفتوح حتى لو انت
حافظت في مكان طب ما انا هطلع لك من مكان
تاني القيم الاسريه هو مصطلح في الفاظ
يمثل الذوق العام في الجدل بحسب الدعوه
التي تطالب بتجميد او الغاء المواد
القانونيه التي حبسنا بسببها من بينما تنص
عليه هذه المواد هي معاقبه من ينشر صورا
ومقاطع فيديو خادشه للحياء بالسجن او
تتضمن اغراءات وفجورا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي هذه مواد حسب الدعوه القانونيه
ظلمت الفتيات المسجونات لان الرقص فن مصري
راسخ في المجتمع على اي حال وفي كل مكان
وزمان سواء عبر شاشات التلفزيون والتراث
السينمائي الذي يخضع لرقابه المصنفات مش
مش مضبوط فيه طبعا بيوت كتير يا رب تتاثر
بالموضوع دوت في اطفال بتشوف الحاجات ديت
فما ينفعش اصلا فلازم الماده تكون موجوده
لكن
الدعوه ستعدي على القيم الاسريه تلقى
اعتراضا ممن يعتبر انها تحفظ عادات
وتقاليد لطالما تمسك بها المجتمع وان
الغائها او تجميدها قد يؤدي الى نوع من
الخروج عن قيم المجتمع بل وربما الانحلال
في نظر البعض وفي كل الاحوال اخذت هذه
القضيه لتضاف الى الجدل القديمه الجديد
جدل تسليم الرايه بين اجيال تؤمن بالقديم
وثوابته واجيال جديده تبحث عن التجديد او
في نظرها المزيد من الحريه وانتم مع من
تتفقون
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات